we're so glad that we're getting bang
like what's that means feel oh yeah it
is do your father steal know who Theo is
I've never met Leon feel 1va ugh that's
how you separate the OVA and you bastard
it via Vaughn we just gotta say I
appreciate you saying that because I
[ __ ] won't do that okay you guys said
that you're right and I won't do that
knowing you owned it respect yeah I own
it dude apologize I will say I'm sorry
about that man you will please just say
one of my car keys fell that's all good
but yeah I don't like that man I used to
have a buddy [ __ ] that would like
every time we were walking and talking
with other people he would like always
like walk a little bit over to me and
I'd be like on the way to school and I
hate that [ __ ] and you brought it up
thank you for making me a better person
I'm serious and I'm not sure when Rogan
would dislike wonder what Chris D'Elia
is at dude he's probably just rich dude
someone said he has four sofas in his
house oh what a piece of [ __ ] at least
there's people that don't have sofas
like in other countries where cats from
and even maybe where probably where I'm
from dude Louisiana has other small
countries yeah
Louisiana some of the most Vietnamese
people in America start Comedy Festival
yes Daddy accom [ __ ] Chris D'Elia calm
that's not a real site Brad Sowder but
somebody is not a real site it's between
Chris and feel you could say master down
low you gotta know two things one of
those things well I agree with the
episode hey Brian I all say over/under
five but as far as guests of the year
Chris what are you gonna do with the
belt if you win though what do you do
with the belt if you win guess the year
yeah what are gonna do with the belt
enough of us there's enough of us in the
race for some reason you do make [ __ ]
90 people for 90 people 90 yeah for some
reason for some reason you made it so
[ __ ] that people could vote for 90 on
lockdown I'm gonna make some nice
[ __ ] dangly earrings for everybody
dildo what with big dicks I would never
wear that into it I'm gonna make [ __ ]
big earrings for me that's the Obi you
know his name don't don't be why is that
a [ __ ] name is saying his name
you're so disrespectful he's he's in the
race video no he doesn't say that dude
you can't just categorize him that way
what what what are you what is your dad
do King are seeing these band-aids broke
he had a king of King immersed in this
Rat King [ __ ] all day bro and look at
the title belt right here something
Chris D'Elia will never have dude and he
can have all kind of stuff he has
someone said in his house he has an
ice-cream maker and if someone said that
that is a Slurpee machine Oh Krystal he
has an ice-cream maker in his house and
doesn't even eat dairy that's why I'm
just there well that's that's
overabundance and that's rich people
doing rich [ __ ] someone said he has for
couches dude and there's a man out there
and a woman out there trying to make
love on a floor somewhere while that
[ __ ] sitting there were four
couches well dude the only ain't a champ
bony never will be oh [ __ ]
and you know it don't see him daliyah
huh come see me dude he's too busy doing
you know doing whatever he does didn't
rich Oh being rich dude someone said he
got a jacket made out of money made a
bunch of
made by a jacket made out of money you
know it's crazy he wanders around his
house hiding money probably around and
then blindfolded himself and going
looking for his own dude I saw Chris
microwave a wad of cash before yeah
microwave he's changed man when I met
him he was a different guy he was gentle
nice cared about his animals
someone said his animals he has like a
group a pet company that comes and takes
him and just brings him around for his
Instagram oh dude and him and Bobby Lee
this is a true story used to go down to
Mexico Chris and my beliefs we got on to
Mexico to get involved with who knows
what but they used to go watch Mexican
comedians perform and steal their
material and bring it back up to America
how crazy is that do his fighting words
and they would steal the Mexican means
we talk in Spanish they translate them
steal back to America who knows what
happened did that I'm just telling you
what I've heard and this is just around
the water huh that's around the water
this around the water cooler but I say
this does a lot of people drinking
around the Waller water cool yeah the
water coos b-dawg dude
I lost guest of the Europe by a percent
1% the [ __ ] is that I didn't post about
[ __ ] I didn't push it I win [ __ ] this
Theo von Lucky's got Chris he's a
colleague please dude he's he's got two
first names he's out he's out what's
your real last name [ __ ] out here Chris
don't be sick babies I kind of let you
down man that's I didn't push it if I
pushed it he's here to do just a couple
things I guess he's gonna do a couple of
impressions
Theo well can you do I think you have a
crystal impression you just burst in
here
[Music]
- that was really good - oh my god back
jeez that's so bad is that Chris Chris
here my his hair is longer than mine and
it's true I swear to God for a second I
thought that was Chris D'Elia oh my god
I'm so honest
Brendan it that's so good daddy [ __ ]
that's always does it hold my leg
Brendan good right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]